you
hi everyone is Jerry there's a clever
trap for white in the Sicilian Russell
emo variation that I'd like to share
with you it's one that has the potential
to trap the black queen win a
significant amount of material other
than the Queen or have the black King
running for his life and basically have
the whole black side in complete
disarray this is a trap I have
first-hand experience with I can say
I've successfully executed this trap
against a Grand Master opponent before
if you're to ask me however what's the
likelihood this trap is to car at a
beginner level or an amateur level I
would say that it is quite low that you
even arrive at the position type we are
soon to observe so as odd as this may
sound I believe that this is a trap more
so for a more experienced player than
anything else for a more experienced
player to a get into and then B fall
form so let me show you how we arrived
at this trap position
efore c5 Knight f3 knight c6 Bishop b5
the rasoolum Oh black now looks to
connect nights with e6 recapturing on c6
and maintaining the structure white
takes the knight out before that's a
possibility B take C b3 white is taking
aim at controlling e5 and I'd also I
don't want to just show the trap in this
video I'd also like to point out a
couple make a couple instructional
points here white has just parted with
their light square bishop a good
strategy for white to try and employ in
this position type is one that limits
blacks light square Bishop makes it such
that its presence is not so easily felt
so if black plays to a six this is not a
good diagonal for the moment it stops
castling but after a move like d6 this
is a rock-solid structure and the bishop
is biting on granite short story this is
a terrible diagonal the bishop is really
not doing a good job at all
therefore black can try to get it out
along this diagonal d6 is a step in that
direction
black with this last move looks to play
e5 next white however can interfere with
this idea by playing e5 right away and
this is a move that black may have
calculated as unplayable because after D
takes e why can't recapture why not if
you'd like to go ahead pause the video
see what my let's just say grandmaster
opponent played in this position what is
the super tempting move for black in
this position okay the move here
Queen to d4 that's a fork both pieces
unprotected what is y to do now well
they put on their beginner cap and play
the ridiculous-looking move Bishop to b2
what in the world is going on that's a
free piece is it up not quite if you
don't take the bishop you're just worse
off you only have one piece develop your
queen site structure terrible you're in
a difficult spot so let's cover Queen
takes Bishop what's the story now well
Knight c3 guess who's short on squares
it's the black queen who only has two
safe squares her current one in a three
squares that the knight on e5 is soon to
take away so if black just develops late
c4 the queen is gone Queen takes rook
would be best okay so black sees this
and says I'm not going to let my Queen
get trapped Bishop a6 defends that move
but there's another move that black has
to be aware of and it's a silent but
deadly move Queen to f3 is an idea but
not just yet the Queen has a
responsibility to defend the rook so
first we get out of this
position where our queen is tied down to
the defense of the rope we play rugby
one chase the Queen away and now we play
Queen f3 what is this queen doing a lot
Queen takes f7 Knight takes f7 Queen
takes c6 with the fork how do you parry
all these threats you don't the best
move in the computer's eyes is a sad one
queenside castle allowing knight takes
here Knight takes rook doing something
other than that like Knight to e7 allows
Queen takes pawn check Queen takes a
threatening mate threatening a fork
bishop here you give a check and simply
castle get some more pieces and involved
guess who's in the center black guess
who's on Castle black guess who has no
development black everything is terrible
about this position and this is a
winning attack for white best move in
the computer's eyes is h5 and we could
just start taking pieces maybe a check
here we're crashing through on the e6
square Knight d5 the attack plays itself
out one last variation to cover is the
one where the black Queen from this
position simply runs away Queen a3 we
once again play this key move Queen f3
this silent but very strong move Queen
f3 yet again this would be the best
continuation and we once again take here
and simply from this point and that
other variation the Bishop is on a6 and
we were able to capture on e6 but from
here we simply get more pieces involved
we complete our development and as
mentioned in the beginning of this video
this is the position where the King is
running for his life and there's just no
coordination whatsoever for black
structural from a structural standpoint
it's just terrible the Queen is out of
play all the pieces still here on their
back rank the knight
he's tethered to the defense of this
pawn otherwise Knight takes c6 is mate
just kind of being familiar with some
ideas here
one to activate your pieces maybe even
d4 and then getting on the D file Knight
to e4 looking to sink into these dark
squares as an idea as well as moving the
Queen away and then we have some
possibility of a fork this is not some
clear cut like this is not some
clear-cut trap little that we would
maybe see out of the two Knights defense
where the game ends in like checkmate
where you could have the start to finish
play out egg you know exactly how the
trap is shown that's not this that's not
how this trap is this is more of
acquiring a strong winning attack here
out of the Sicilian Rhossili mo but yeah
this is one that I wanted to share with
you it's super cool that's to see this
Bishop to b2 move I know I was really
surprised when I first found out about
this reviewing it with the computer
Bishop to b2 looks completely ridiculous
but yeah in the end it's really black
who is getting themself into a world of
hurt let's just say so as usual feel
free to leave any feedback to this video
in the comment section below and as
usual I hope you got something out of or
maybe just enjoyed seeing this neat
little trick out of the Sicilian Rasul
emo that's all for now take care bye
you